Asalam alalaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends. I
came across this story experiment. I
found it so amazing and so unique. I've
never seen anything like that. Subhan
Allah. Uh brothers and sisters, you're
going to be watching in this is
somewhere in Africa where I don't know
exactly where, but this man dresses
himself up to be a homeless person, a
poor person, and then his friend dressed
up to be a rich person. He goes to
churches and he goes to mosques to see
which one will let the poor person in
and which one will reject it. Well,
we're going to find out now in watch for
ourselves, guys. Subhan Allah, how that
turns out when he goes and visits
churches and this also teaches a big big
lesson subhan Allah about the
worshippers uh and not only that the
foundations on where these places are
built on subhan Allah humility or
arrogance let's wash ourselves inshallah
everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die that's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until the grace brothers and sisters
Masid Norway, the one that we built is
looking to another masjid around the
area of Norway. Subhan Allah, where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
£500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count, brothers and sisters.
And believe me, if every single one of
us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000, that's
going to be something you will never
regret on your makyama. And everything
that you lose is going to perish and go.
But your deeds on your makama are not.
Donate to the link in the video.
I'm playing no follow.
But this is my brother's house now.
>> This is your father. I was from your
father's house.
>> I cannot go now.
I will make you idiot.
>> No.
Me. I don't got a place to go.
>> So this the first church he goes to. So
there's a poor man. He's there and it
seems gated. There's um guns, etc. Let's
Let's see.
>> Wait. Hold on. Hold on.
Oh,
[Music]
>> the service is so bad now.
>> So, you can clearly say he said, "I want
to go in and pray." That's all he said.
He just got a bag. He's homeless. He's
saying, "I just want to go and pray."
They they they reject him.
[Music]
Huh?
Go back. Go back. Go back.
over
now. No, go like this.
>> Okay, here they get a bit more
aggressive. They close the gates and
he's got a machine gun and he's like,
"Go, go, go, go, go." Yeah. And it's
like, "What is it? What kind of what
kind of a church is this?" Um, so you
can see very arrogant. And I'm not
saying every Christian is like that. We
cannot come put everyone in the same
category. But churches have become
places of money. Yes. You've got people
buying jets, literally 20 million pound
jets for Jesus name. Yeah. And people
are being scammed. Okay. being scammed
as you can see. Subhan Allah. And you
can hear they're getting more like
aggressive with him and he's just
saying, "Look, I just want to go pray."
>> No,
>> I said good idea.
>> I want to go I want to GO AND PRAY.
>> BUT IT'S church now.
>> No, go
want to allow me to go inside.
Hey, go like this.
>> I want to enter the church.
>> So, this is the third church he goes to.
He wants to enter. So, look at the
reaction of the people.
>> Today,
>> go back.
>> I want to enter.
>> I hope you have praise God.
>> I'll go inside the church here.
>> What?
>> No. No.
No. No,
>> we've closer.
>> My father not get under the
>> This is the fourth church he goes to.
Subhan Allah. Fourth church. So you
can't really say it's just one, two.
This is like you've seen a common
pattern here now.
>> By 7:30 is true. Okay. So by
>> my father
my brother Niger
from this place.
>> But sir, this is my father's house now.
>> This is your father's car. House from
your father's house. I
>> I cannot go now.
>> You cannot go and pray. So he's saying
this is my father house because they
refer to God as the father and he's
saying yeah get out your father's house
terrible
>> make you and I will make you go
[Music]
>> hello
>> okay so this is the fifth church this is
the fifth church he's at Wow that's
that's
[Music]
my mouth for lying down.
>> Well, they close the door at him.
>> So, here is rich friend turns up and
look at their attitude towards the rich
friend at these churches.
[Music]
If you want go here before I begin
sticking
I do no good for man come inside track
tonight know me
>> he say
>> you can see this guy's just rich they
don't even know who he is but because he
looks wealthy in a in a car their
attitude and tones changes straight away
and you know what's not crazy because we
believe in Islam the poor are going to
enter paradise 50,000 years before the
rich because the rich have more to
account for yes with the money they
spend how they spent it how they earned
it what they did with it they spin to
halal haram or good etc. So Islam gives
and that's what the prophet if I'm not
mistaken he said that hope he is um he
will be with the poor okay and we know
how the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him was with the poor people and how he
treated them and the people that were
around him the prophetam he was known to
be kind he was never known um to shout
or scold people you know subhan allah so
the poor are really really something
where Allah even tells us in the Quran
that when you give money to the poor or
the beggar give and say I'm only giving
this for the sake sake of God. Not that
I want a thank you from you or any kind
of benefit. This is what's beautiful
about Islam. When we do acts of deeds,
good deeds, Muslims are known of the
biggest charity givers. We give it for
the sake of God. Not that I want
something in return. Yes. Even if you
insult me, no problem. I did not do that
for you or with a conditional that, oh,
you're not going to insult me back.
Irrelevant. I'm going to help you
because I want to help you. And God
reminds us that we do it for the right
reasons and not to show off. Because we
know the first free people to enter
hellfire are Muslims who claim to do
things for other than God for God. But
they didn't. They did it to show off.
Oh, I give him charity to the poor so
people can say I'm a wealthy. I'm such a
generous man. Yeah. So you can see the
attitude towards that.
>> Make you pray now. You don't say beside
church now for everybody.
>> No. The people of the church they will
not know.
>> Officer, what do you think? I assume
that you see somebody beside you. What
are you going to be?
>> So you people will not allow him in. So
they will not be
>> actually officer this man is so we don't
dress like this to check if we allow
this the house of God and I believe
everybody else
>> if it's the house of God it should be
welcome to anybody anybody but they've
turned it into a a club yeah only the
elite can come or only certain people
and that's terrible and look at now when
he goes to a mosque yeah look at when he
goes to a mosque guys and look at the
attitude completely changes yeah this is
where it gets really profound
Is that
[Music]
>> what you want?
>> I will everything free.
I mean I pray with now.
>> No.
I come inside.
So you can see he wants to say he's
saying he wants to learn how to pray.
And by the way we have a charity guys
Salah Pro. Download the app inshallah.
You can order guided prayer mats from
there if you don't know how to pray
salah or know how to do wudoo. We
actually help with that. So I just
wanted to add that in there. It's called
Salah Pro on Android on iOS. Guys, you
can download it and get your guided
prayer map for absolutely free and it
will teach you how to pray salah and how
to do wudoo. Download those app
inshallah. And you can see here guys,
they automatically help him. Those guys
say, you know, we can teach you how to
do wudoo. Subhan Allah. You know why?
Cuz the house of Allah the foundations
based on what? We genuinely believe in
one true God and Islam is the truth. And
to us, we don't care if you're black,
green, yellow, blue, poor, rich, it
doesn't matter. That's why when we go
Mecca, everyone's dressed the same. You
know why? So nobody can uh show off
anything. We're all the same. And we're
wearing an outfit that we're all going
to wear when we die. This is how
beautiful Islam is. And you can see this
in action. Look.
You have to watch your
wash. There was no thing of you're poor,
you're this. Straight away teach him how
to do woo because this is what shows you
the beauty of Islam. And that's the
reason why so many people are trying to
portray Islam in a certain way which is
not. And this man if I'm not mistaken
he's a Christian himself if I'm not
mistaken. Yeah. But what a beautiful
experiment showing the reality. And this
doesn't mean that every Christians are
like this. Of course it's Christians
that you know accept anyone as well. It
just shows you the reality of certain
places and how it's institutionalized
and it's all about you know clubs or you
know you're you're a member.
>> Okay. Okay. After that you have to wash
your mouth.
>> Yes. Okay. Then after that you're going
to wash your nose.
>> My nose. Thanks. Then after wash
look like
>> now he goes to another mosque. Let's see
what happens there.
I want to go I want to go to
he goes to the sister and the sister
goes and gets him a water so he can do
voodoo. Yeah. Straight away instantly.
[Music]
I want to pray here. I wash my hand.
>> I wash it three times.
Let me let me Okay.
[Music]
is h no I just want to say they very
good I am not a Muslim man so it's just
like I'm coming here for the first time
so I don't know how you people do
something so that woman give me that
water she she very nice to me she so I
want to know how treat person day like
this I see that you people don't look
down on anybody that you guys allow
anybody regardless of how they look like
see the way I
>> no we can allow you on this way now
>> mama Yeah.
>> So you can see that he's thanking now
them and saying you know what thank you
for not judging me the way I'm appearing
dressed etc. And guys subhan Allah it
just shows you subhan Allah when
something is the foundations are on
truth and truthhood um you see the like
the fruits of it. Subhan Allah. So guys
subhan Allah as you can see uh it was a
beautiful experiment. And I've never
seen anything like that. Alhamdulillah.
And it just shows you subhan Allah that
we should be have humility and accept
anybody because we do not know a man who
you deem to be poor in the kingdom of
God Almighty in Allahh's kingdom. He
might be the most rich and you might see
someone who is like Pharaoh who has
everything that anyone can wish for and
he's the most despised person. And
that's why in Islam we do not and do not
judge people based on their wealth and
status. We should never do that. And
always honor the poor and always honor
those who are less fortunate. Subhan
Allah. And this is the beauty of Islam.
Explore Islam for yourselves if you guys
are watching this. That's all I want to
do in s and react to that. It was sent
to me by brother Abbas. May Allah bless
him. And what a beautiful reaction.
Subhan Allah. And yes, that's all I have
to share with you guys. Inshallah,
sisters, do not forget to support the
cause inshallah at the beginning and uh
donate for the sake of Allah subhanaa
tala to help those poor people who are
more in need.
better.